the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge know
these tours can always be a diplomatic
dance after years of difficult brexit
negotiations between the UK and Ireland
William wasn't shying away from the fact
that damage has been done and
relationships need to be rebuilt
of course the changing relationship
between the UK and the EU will require
us to work together to ensure that the
relationship between Ireland and the UK
remains just as strong legal treaties
are vital in underpinning the
relationships between states but
relationships between people are equally
if not more essential especially between
the people of our two countries whose
lives histories and futures are so
deeply intertwined adding that his
generation must never forget the efforts
that were made for peace it is right
that we continue to remember those who
suffered as a consequence of our
troubled past and whilst many wrongs
have been done it is important that we
are not bound by these it is vital the
people of my generation and generations
to come never take for granted the
progress we have made together
we must recommit ourselves to the path
of friendship and understanding a
message of friendship viewed is highly
significant by their Irish hosts
[Music]
since the referendum we've heard many
speeches from members of the royal
family on European tours but this is
probably the most significant yet with
Prince William actually talking about
the UK leaving the EU and now the
importance of rebuilding relationships
and friendships that have been damaged
by breakfast it's not their place to be
political but walk along the cliffs to
look out over the Irish Sea towards the
UK was more than just a gentle photo
opportunity a reminder that we are
neighbors with a shared history and
shared bond that the royal family are
determined to play their part to protect
Rhiannon Mills Sky News in Dublin